My name is Jennifer Lippincott-Schwartz
and I work at the National
Institute of Health.
Today I'd like to talk about
the role of lipids
and cholesterol in the regulation of
trafficking across the secretory pathway.
Now lipids are a major component
of the secretory pathway
so it's important to try to understand
what roles they play
other than just as a conveyer
of or a constituent
of the bilayer that comprises this system.
Before I get into describing
what the roles of these lipids
might be in regulating the
secretory pathway
let me first give you a
perspective of this system.
The secretory pathway is characteristic
of all eukaryotic cells
and is comprised
of three major compartments:
the endoplasmic reticulum, the Golgi
and the plasma membrane
as well as transporting intermediates
that flow between these
different organelles.
Newly synthesized proteins that enter
the secretory pathway
do so at the level of the
endoplasmic reticulum
where they get processed and folded
and then transported
to the Golgi apparatus through
small vesicular
tubular carriers into the Golgi apparatus
where they then meet up
with a variety of
different enzymes that can process
these proteins.
And ultimately the proteins then move into
a different set of carriers
that ferry them to the plasma membrane
or to other final destinations within the cell.
Now traditionally people who have studied
this very dynamic  system
have focused on the role of proteins
of this machinery in regulating the trafficking
between these different compartments.
And important roles for coat proteins,
small GTPases,
tethering factors and fusion proteins
have all been found to play important roles
in this process by which molecules
move from one place to another
within the system.
And this movie is just showing you
an example
of these dynamic movements,
where transported intermediates are forming
of the surface of the ER and are targeting
to the Golgi apparatus
found in this central region here
through this very complex protein-based
machinery.
Now, less understood is the roles of lipids
in this process.
Clearly lipids are important
because they form
the bilayer into which proteins
are conveyed
within this secretory system.
But do lipids help orchestrate
other features of this system.
Are they regulating
in a more fundamental way
the way that the membranes are organized
and proteins are flowing within this system.
That's the question
that I think is very very interesting.
Now there are three major classes of lipids
that comprise the secretory pathway.
These include glycerophospholipids,
sphingolipids
and cholesterol.
And these three lipids have very different
characteristics
when they exist within a bilayer.
The glycerophospholipids have fatty acid tails
that have a lot of essentially
unsaturated carbon atoms
which make them flexible
when they sit in a bilayer
and as a result the thickness of that bilayer
is relatively thin relative to bilayers
that are enriched in sphingolipids
which have longer
and more saturated fatty acids
associated with them.
Now, in the presence of cholesterol
which is a flat four carbon
chained sterol molecule,
the sphingolipids will become
much more tightly packed
and as a result create a thicker bilayer
relative to bilayers
that are enriched in the
glycerophospholipids.
Now, one of the things
that's interesting is
that when you recombined
these different lipids
in an artificial vesicle
you can see essentially segregation
of these lipids into different microdomains
with cholesterol
and sphingolipids essentially coalescing
into discrete microdomains
relative to the phosphoglycerol,
the glycerophospholipids,
which distribute more uniformly
within these vesicles.
Now interestingly, there is,
it's known that there is
a gradient of lipid composition
of these three classes of lipids
across the secretory pathway.
The ER is primarily enriched
in glycerophospholipids
and that is in contrast,
in striking contrast
to the plasma membrane which is enriched
in sphingolipids and sterols.
The Golgi apparatus has a mixed richness.
So, it’s got an intermediate composition
between plasma membrane
and ER-like lipid.
Now, this gradient of composition
of these lipids
across the secretory pathway
presumably plays an important role
in the discrete functions
of these organelles within the system.
So, the ER is shown here,
which is primarily enriched
in these glycerophospholipids,
has lipids therefore that are loosely
packed and deformable
which makes them suitable for insertion
and folding of proteins which is
the primary function of the endoplasmic
reticulum vis-a-vis
the secretory pathway.
The plasma membrane by contrast
is enriched in sphingolipids
and cholesterol.
This makes this bilayer thicker and
less permeable to small molecules
which provides an impermeable barrier
to the outside and also allows
the plasma membrane
to be moved and manipulated
by the cytoskeleton as shown here
where you are looking at the interaction
of the actin cytoskeleton
with the plasma membrane
at the cells leading edge.
The Golgi apparatus is intermediate
in concentration
between these different phospholipids
and cholesterol.
And it's function within
the secretory pathway
could potentially be optimized as a result
of that mixed concentration
because it's situated between the ER
and the plasma membrane
and is essentially
where sorting decisions are made
as to whether
proteins essentially leave
the ER-Golgi system
or move on to the plasma membrane.
So one of the biggest questions in the field
is how this lipid gradient
across the secretory pathway
is generated and maintained.
I just emphasized how
this lipid gradient
can play a very important role
in the functions
of these different organelles
so how this gradient
is maintained and generated
is an important question.
Now, we know that cholesterol
is synthesized in the ER
but is shipped very efficiently
out to the Golgi apparatus
and on the plasma membrane.
What explains this we don't know.
One possibility is that proteins
essentially can partition
with cholesterol and help
drive that molecule
into the Golgi apparatus which is where
the sphingolipids
are preferentially synthesized.
The cholesterol and sphingolipids
could then potentially
partition with each other
to drive the movement
of that population of molecules
on to the plasma membrane.
But there are complexities to this system.
For instance, cholesterol
is capable of coming out
of the bilayer altogether and associate
with lipid-transfer proteins
which are cytosolic proteins
that can potentially deliver cholesterol
throughout this system.
So, it's not clear how
cholesterol really could
be regulated in this system to drive
these different partitioning events
if it also has this dynamic component
where it can exchange
within the cytoplasm.
So, we need to try to understand
how all of these lipids are behaving
within the system.
Which is going to require ability to
have better lipid probes
to monitor these lipids
as they are floxing and distributing
within this system as well as
visualizing the composition
of these different organelles,
visibly lipids and the proteins
that are distributed with them.
Now, another question that
relates to what I just mentioned
with regards to that lipid gradient
is whether
that gradient itself is playing a role
in protein sorting and trafficking
within the secretory pathway.
And the reason for thinking about this
is that transmembrane proteins
favor being
in a lipid environment that matches
the length or their transmembrane domain.
So proteins that have long
transmembrane domains
will tend to want to reside
in a lipid environment
that's enriched in sphingolipids
and cholesterol,
whereas a protein with a short
transmembrane domain
will prefer to be in an
environment enriched
in these glycerophospholipids.
So, that let many to hypothesize
that the way proteins actually
distribute within the secretory pathway
is through their moving
and partitioning to particular lipid
environments
that fit their transmembrane domain.
And consistent with that
researchers have shown
that by modifying the length
of the transmembrane domain
of a protein you can shift its distribution
within the secretory pathway.
Now a third question relates to whether
this partitioning of the lipids
within this system
can be integrated with protein machinery
to play a key role in the way
that this secretory pathway
is actually acting to sort and traffic protein.
And here is an incredibly
I think the most probably
the most profound questionable,
we know a lot about this protein machinery
that's driving secretory trafficking
but we don't know how this machinery
is actually
influenced by these lipid gradients
that I just mentioned
and how that lipid that protein machinery
can itself potentially impact
the lipid partitioning and the segregation
of these lipids across the secretory pathway
in order to allow this system
to really operate in a robust fashion
where newly synthesized proteins
can very efficiently move to this system
out to the plasma membrane.
So, with that I want to thank you.